Miranda Santos gave his State of the
State and I wanted to show you a couple
clips from it and I will leave it up to
you to decide for yourself whether you
think the vision that this guy Florida
man Ron DeSantis is putting forth is a
vision of a country and a state that you
would want to live in that protects your
rights cares about you as the individual
doesn't believe that it is designed to
govern over you forever or if you think
Joe Biden's better and we'll juxtapose
some DeSantis and Biden Clips Florida
has become the Escape patch for those
chafing under authoritarian arbitrary
and seemingly never-ending mandates and
restrictions and the kids used to come
up and reach in the pool and rub my leg
down so it was traded and then watch the
hair come back up again they look at it
so I learned about roaches I learned
about kids jumping on my lap
and I've Loved kids jumping on my lap we
reject the biomedical Security State
that curtails Liberty ruins livelihoods
and divides our society and we will
protect the rights of individuals to
live their lives and Corn Pop was a bad
dude provided our businesses with the
ability to prosper fought back against
unconstitutional Federal mandates
look here's a deal here's the deal even
today Across the Nation we see students
denied an education due to Reckless
politically motivated school closures
workers denied employment due to
heavy-handed mandates your line dog face
Pony soldiers in Florida we have
protected the right of our citizens to
earn a living well these truth to be
self-evident all men and women created
by the goal you know this you know the
thing they are grounded more in blind
adherents to faulty and declarations
than they are in the Constitutional
Traditions that are the foundation of
free Nations
Florida is a free state let's go Brandon
I agree all right I don't want to be
heavy-handed though so I'm not even
going to say any more about this you
guys just take all of that and think
about how you want to go forward with
your life what type of person would you
want governing Someone Like You
DeSantis or quarterback you decide